so speaking of heroes and villains and
highs and lows you grew up in las vegas
and you said that vegas is a performing
town a town of high stakes drama and
eccentricity
it's a town of high highs and low lows
and i'll be damned if my therapist
didn't point that correlation out to me
personally a long time ago
uh
so to me
vegas
from the outside is romanticized by
certain movies the lows define
the beauty of this town
and certain movies
so timmy casino
uh
with robert de niro joe pesci and sharon
stone
leaving las vegas with nicholas cage if
you're unloading
in las vegas with uh
uh
with the
chinese thompson
first of all what's your favorite
representation of vegas from a darker
side and do you draw any wisdom insight
from the
the
the darkness the lows and the highs from
in in those movies or is it over
romanticized
so i i grew up in a really conservative
mormon family
and vegas was
established by the mormons and the mob
those were like the two
very different
worlds that created what vegas is and if
you live in vegas
it really shows in a lot of ways because
vegas has
the you know the strip and the parties
and the craziness but it also has
very like neighborhoods and and big
families and
conservative people and and
and liberal people living together in a
really interesting way
and
for me
growing up here
for instance was a lot of like driving
on the freeway my mom being like
children close your eyes there's a naked
woman on that billboard and everything
okay mom on our way to church you know
what i mean it was like but also being
like whoa this is crazy this is you know
anything like
taking in whatever i could when i could
yeah yeah um
so
i saw
and i'm grateful for that like i really
love that i didn't grow up as a mormon
in for instance like utah or something
like the typical place because i i saw
both sides and i appreciated something
from both sides and now as a person now
who's not religious but just spiritually
minded
you know i i
i i i'm grateful for that
divergent character that juxtaposition
dual edged sword that vegas is and i try
to apply that to everything in life
which is
like johnny depp in the amber it's like
there's two sides to every story there's
always two sides to every coin there's
always and there's something to be said
for both like i try to see people and
and
even if you know it's just yeah i try to
apply that to life as far as a movie
that personifies vegas or or something
and that medium that personifies vegas
in a way that
that resonates with me don't say
hangover
no no yeah
i i also like i wasn't even allowed to
watch pg-13 movies growing up so i a lot
of the movies that you're saying like i
i didn't i either didn't see i didn't
have cable television
you know i wasn't like a pilgrim but i
had a really really conservative
upbringing so it didn't define
your intellectual like development
no no i just uh i can't think of any
movie that comes to mind where i'm like
that's my vegas movie you know what i
mean like i'm sure i've seen some of the
movies you've said now but i don't i
can't think of one that i'm like
actually personifies vegas in a way
that feels honest to me like or or like
wasn't there a chevy chip was there a
chevy chase yeah yeah i think that's
maybe the only one i thought of that
came to mind where i was like because i
love chevy chase so much that maybe it's
one of his uh vegas vegas vacation or
something yeah so but that's more like
lighthearted yeah surge that kind of
stuff right it's not like i guess what i
would say is there's no truth pers that
has been that i've seen of vegas because
what i see at vegas is
uh
there's obviously like the parties and
stuff in the life which i'm not a big
party person so i haven't really
experienced much of that but i've also
there's also drugs and i've i have a
strange relationship with drugs because
i've lost a few friends to drug
overdoses and so i don't roman that's
not romantic to me but there's also like
uh
yeah i mean you asked for a dark
reflection of it i could i guess i
certainly see a dark reflection to vegas
and i don't i feel like vegas is
typically personified as like at the
tables never exist but it's also like
i have like friends who've lost all
their money to gambling addiction and
and so it's like
what i guess
yeah somebody maybe needs to make maybe
that's an open spot there needs to be a
dark side to vegas
about mormons in vegas that's just
overdose or getting shot by the mob yeah
you